في منتخب البرازيل مع منتخب الكاميرون في
استاد يوسير خلف اليوم في الجوله الثالثه
والاخيره من دوري المجموعات لبطوله كاس
العالم قطر 2022
وسيخوض منتخب البرازيل المباراه وهو على
قمه المجموعه السابعه بالعلامه الكامله
ومعه بطاقه العبور لدور ال16 منذ صباح يوم
امس ارتفع عدد المشجعين في شوارع الدوحه
وهم يرتدون الوان المنتخب البرازيلي
الاصفر والاخضر حطت في مطار حمد الدولي
هنا في قطر سبع طائرات ضخمه قادمه من
البرازيل تحمل مشجع المنتخب كما حضر عدد
الغفير من البرازيليين المقيمين في دول
الخليج والبلدان العربيه لحضور المباراه
وتشييع منتخب امام مشجعين منتخب الكاميرون
فهم مستعدون لتشييع منتخب بلادهم الذي
يشارك للمره الثامنه في تاريخه في منافسات
كاس العالم الكثير منهم وصل الى الدوحه
قبل طب قليلا من انطلاق صافره المونديال
جالبين معهم الاجواء الافريقيه الساحره
بالوانها من مميزه واحاذجهم مختلفه لتتحول
معهم شوارع قتال وملاعبها الى كرنفال مليء
بالمرح ومتعب كره القدم والروح الرياضيه
الايجابيه من امام استاذ لوسيل لقيت بزاري
العربيه الدوحه دوله قطر